[music playing]
- Ingrid Visser and Kina
Scollay are looking for evidence
that Orca are hunting
great white sharks
in New Zealand waters.
Ingrid has evidence that
there's a disturbing pattern
in Orca hunting.
New Zealand Orca are hunting
Sevengill sharks, just
like the South African Orca.
Sevengill sharks grow to nine
feet long and 200 pounds,
a much larger meal for
an Orca than a small ray.
But the Sevengill
shark is no easy prey.
- Sevengills are relatively
new on the Orca menu.
But I've seen it
a few times now.
You see the Orca,
and they're very,
very precise in how they do it.
And I've got footage of
Orca with the Sevengills,
where they've ripped
the pectoral fin
right under the
pectoral girdle there,
and they've extracted the liver.
[voices exclaiming]
- Shark!
Shark!
- One of the things
I find fascinating
is how the Sevengills will
actually turn and defend
themselves against the Orca.
The way the Orca
hunt the Sevengills
is pretty impressive.
First of all, they'll
come in and they'll
karate chop the shark.
So they'll just come
and lift their tail
up and whack them on the back.
Then they grab the sharks by the
pectoral fin and rip them open
and pull the livers out.
- Ingrid captured rare footage
of Orcas hunting Sevengills
in northern New Zealand.
Their precision in hunting
for shark liver is clear.
[music playing]